hey guys we are so excited yes today we
build the floor let's go do it
oh come on someone take your hands look
dirty
[Music]
Sarah and I sketched up some plans some
ideas of what we wanted to overall shape
to be of like a Russian nesting doll
theme hitting me in the face
keep that hand now we knew what we
wanted the ceilings to look like and we
knew we wanted these like floating
hallway bridges and then we sent those
sketches over to my dad he is an
engineer and he actually drew them up
made them legitimate this is what we
always do we come up with an idea and
then we say dad can you make this
actually work in the real world he says
yes it took a lot of back-and-forth
between us and him he got us the plans
and yeah that's it so far we've already
dug out the pit to lay the foundation
and the footing we built up the brick
stem walls we filled them with grout we
put in the anchor bolts we put it in the
hole down to be put in the all thread
all thread through the hold downs
anchor bolts 5-8 now we're ready to
build the floor so we're gonna put down
the mudsill the sill plate we're gonna
roll out them joists and then we're
gonna slide on that plywood and then
we're gonna dance a little bit we're
gonna get Ranger the dog to go
skateboarding on it you have Ranger
skateboards inserts if of Ranger key
[Music]
that's the goal and that's what we're
gonna show you today
[Music]
we're building the floor my buddy
Scottie he drove out from New Hampshire
that's like over 3600 miles he came with
his dog rocky it was not just the two of
us he's back filling the foundation
right now getting it ready for us to
jump up there and start building the
floor what makes this project different
than other projects is that normally you
know you would have a different
contracting company come in and through
the foundation then we could start doing
the floor and then you might have
somebody come in and you know you have a
lot of shingles E of this e of that but
when it's just three people doing
everything from the ground to the roof
it makes you so invested into it it's
something extremely special to be able
to create my friend's house you know
with them and be tied in to that forever
[Music]
this is not the way it tapes it be doing
any concrete wear it just W tape were
you flushed before oh yeah that's nice
[Music]
so these are not gonna be perfectly
straight right now they're kind of
slightly crooked but we can like bend
around them they're straight enough for
government work or hippie work okay
these run these longer pieces of
threaded rod run all the way down
through the cinderblock and all the
grout down into the footing and actually
in some cases through the footing for an
additional 12 inches of more footing
anyway these all thread sorry she's
shaking her head ma these are kind of
for the same thing these are just
shorter little bolts that go in just
about that deep they just hold this
bottom plate on which is the mudsill the
first part that transitions concrete
stone to wood and so to mark those we
just tap go along and tap each one right
here and then that's gonna mark it we're
gonna flip it over we're gonna drill a
hole again and then we're gonna put it
back down again
we age there's the indentation that we
just made it what I'm going to do is
drill it out
[Music]
[Music]
so right now we're putting on the rim
joists for the smallest cabin which is
gonna be the living room as you can see
it's raining but that's pretty par for
the course
[Music]
still wants to come down another eighth
of an inch we're gonna rip it we're
gonna grip it in look at that what are
we gonna do you're always chill dude
Jennifer joke no not about me
[Applause]
all right good that's good good did you
lose it again
I would say it is lost not that I lost
it this morning found it and guess what
is right here when you're doing your yes
ma'am stuff yes ma'am I'll never do that
again
i freakin call that kidding me you lost
it already I don't know it's just found
it sir has officially passed her secret
examination I haven't intentionally been
dropping this bit again and again see
see dude you tell me to watch my mouth
cheap-ass my colors success I won't be
dropping this to test you again
[Music]
this flush on the bottom was that gapped
out over there this actually this not
should have only been one [ __ ] do you do
that to all of them no sweet running
yeah
that's why Scotty's a genius cuz he only
sub one board side cuz he only it's the
bet on on the side he only he only
screws up one board yeah this is this
thing is [ __ ] crazy boat up okay
let's get another one of these Tim locks
in here and bring this down
[ __ ] that's a little annoyed because
it's late
we're tired right now let's move the
joist out and they start doing it got
its way we'll roll these things up well
call tonight people
oh yeah okay sounds good yeah so you
want I mean we can finish it today got
one left baby oh yeah I hate this pit up
and let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
okay hold on wait don't you want to do
this last thing okay fine we'll go make
tacos
this is about the height will be
standing there
you got your 3/4 and subfloor the 3/4
exploring this is the height I'm above
the pay now I won't fall in the pier I
will fall in though babe
[Music]
[Music]
stay tuned we've been going all day
non-stop but it's starting to come
together Lanie
we have been
that's looking really cool what I just
got crazy goose I know but now choose
your character sub zero bruh wait let's
not do that just you know the wall look
I shouldn't have to say this but if you
do this sort of [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
those joists and that walkway and then
we're done for the night
[Music]
today was amazing we transitioned from
concrete to would not only that how
could I ever forget dot risen three
foundations from the ground and now
connected have become one unity you're
doing great you guys don't need me at
all might as well just stand here then
no let's go can you do this yes Scotty
can do it none where loses Sarah
cuz it's late and it's been a long day
tomorrow we're putting the plywood on
the floor and good night
[Music]
the three of us are working together
like a well-oiled machine this is
awesome go
[Music]
[Music]
24/7 it is day three on the floor system
Sara's gluing putting the adhesive down
Scotty's drilling the holes it has gone
on nearly flawlessly we're about to put
the plywood on the last section of the
house so I'm gonna get to it we're gonna
finish this last little bit up and we'll
see you soon
five and a half and three and 3/8
[Music]
we did it alright let's nail this thing
off and get dance
[Music]
do you love it I love it you can do dust
angels this the tithing one is bigger
than the floor print of the diamond
cabin that we've been living in this
makes me so excited I thought you said
this was gonna be way too small no this
is big it's huge it's a party Ranger you
finally have a hardwood floor to
skateboard on yeah go oh my gosh it's a
skateboarding dog
let's go skating now I'm in the kitchen
hey babe yeah all the way over them in
the kitchen I can't cuz her house is so
brick when we say it's big it's big to
us because this is still a very very
tiny house yeah thank you everyone thank
you for watching so far cabin last
season - thank you so much to everyone
on patreon this is one of my favorite
parts we're finally up out of the mud we
got a floor what happens next
growing up with walls in the roof
so more excitement to come
[Music]
as you can see we've been busy
[Music]
if using this forklift to get these up
onto the buildings doesn't work we are
in trouble they're big and they're heavy
that's a big drop and crushed